hello everybody and welcome to this
episode of
into the impossible podcast today's
guest is professor paul sutter who is an
amazing
highly passionate hilarious energetic
effervescent astronomer
who's really turned most of his
intellectual endeavors to
the realm of public science
communication
he's involved with emmy-winning
productions and media
dance troops but he's a hardcore
scientist too
and i learned a lot from him i agree
with him on a lot of things
i found it fascinating to hear his
perspective on whether or not scientists
should
basically be forced to learn how to
communicate
as we learn how to communicate or learn
about quantum mechanics
should we not have an obligation to
bring our
research our findings our passion to the
general public because you guys pay our
salary
so anyway i want to ask you to subscribe
to the podcast just hit that little bell
over here over there
whether you're watching on itunes
watching on itunes
listening on itunes or watching on
youtube please subscribe and leave a
rating because actually the algorithm
is uh truly based on the number of
comments
likes subscribes etc that we get so
the more we can do that the more great
guests we can get stay tuned for
coming future great guests including
nobel prize winners and losers and
all sorts of fun things coming up
including a live
stargazing party with uh adam reese
nobel laureate wendy friedman and others
on november 10th 2020 and if you're
listening to this in the future
and the world has not been destroyed the
universe has not come to an end as
documented
the many different ways it can be
documented in this book by paul sutter
today's guest
how to die in space then i will see you
in the future
for now signing off and imploring you to
enjoy
going into the impossible with brian
keating
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
welcome to the into the impossible
podcast i am your fearful host
during these pandemic podcasts and today
we have professor paul
suter am i saying it right paul it's
sutter like butter with an s
all right and you're silky smooth and my
mother used to say
uh you're so smooth you're so cool that
butter doesn't melt in your mouth so
that's how i will remember it
uh you know there's that book
jonathan four called moonwalking with
einstein
about how he became the world's memory
champion
uh u.s memory champion i forget uh but
that was by memorizing
you take someone's you know name and you
equate it to some physical
characteristics and now i will never
make that mistake with with professor
paul suter no i'm just kidding
sutter sutter like butter phd dr
paul center how are you doing today sir
i'm doing fantastic
especially given the climate we're in i
know it's kind of crazy i'm hoping to
have this podcast
out after november 3rd if
november 3rd does not result in another
way to die on earth and i want to get
into that but
of course if the earth doesn't die uh
but maybe you know some of these things
that you talk about these deadly
phenomena
of the extraterrestrial world aren't
looking so bad compared to some of the
stuff going on on this
terra firma you know what when venus
looks appealing
you know we really got reconsider i know
i'm looking for real estate there so
uh where are you calling us uh where are
we speaking to you over the
over the phone lines uh at this moment
are you at the cca
where are you located currently uh so i
am based out of
new york city i'm in my home office
right now and like you mentioned the cca
i do
have a visiting position at the flatiron
institute's
center for computational astrophysics
and also i am a research professor
at stony brook university's institute
for advanced
computational science which is way
better than the institute for basic
computational science
or advanced studies it's like what are
they doing over there they don't even
know what they're studying
these guys scratching it yeah
well you may or may not know stony brook
is my ancestral homeland i was born
at uh the state university of new york
uh right there
my father was a professor of mathematics
along with jim simons
uh who was the founding chairman of the
math department that's
it is now super rich yes and it is now
yeah it is now called you've got a
branding a rebranding it's now stony
brook university which is uh
very different radically different from
those trying to be cool fit in with 21st
century
yeah it's sunni was too confusing i
guess for other people but uh anyway
shorter is better
and i keep you know whenever i read the
title of this book i have this uh
uh song that goes through my mind and i
can't i can't get out of my mind but
it's like um
it's like how to get along or like how
to die anyway i've been singing how to
leave that to you yeah i've been singing
that's right let's ask a space man not
ask a musician
[Music]
what inspired you to write this book uh
as last i checked we're not that likely
to even get off the earth any time soon
let alone to go
to the heart of sagittarius a star tell
me what inspired you to do this
what did the publishers say when you
pitched this book proposal to them
when i when i pitched this book i said
look i i tell all these stories in my
podcast
and media appearances and everything and
it's just
fun and the whole point of the book is
to explore this
amazing astrophysics on all sorts of
scales and
all sorts of locations in a really fun
lighthearted way the whole point of the
book is to have
an excuse to talk about awesome
astrophysics because just saying like
here's a book about astrophysics isn't
going to sell a lot of titles to
publishers or the general public but
then if you say
here's how you can die by learning about
astrophysics like that that gets people
interested
now i remember you know reading and my
wife asked me what are you why are you
reading a book about how to die in space
and i was driving on a long drive with
my kids and i had the choice of you know
putting on a podcast
you know one of my podcasts or listening
to the audiobook as i did of how to die
in space
and they're like turn this podcast off
we want to know how you're going to die
in space
and it just so happened my my
seven-year-old was very curious about
um the very first chapter was actually
perfect for him he was actually
wondering about you know how long could
you would you immediately die
if you go into space as this cover
artist has
and you you don't lose your head as this
guy's losing his head i don't know
we'll flash it up on the post-production
but um uh if you took off your helmet
are you gonna die
as my seven-year-old suspects yeah
you're gonna die but not
right away um like the first thing
that's gonna happen to you is once
you're exposed to vacuum
all the air in your lungs is gonna go
out and don't you dare try to hold it in
because your throat
in those little slimy muscles are not
designed to hold in a lung full of air
against vacuum
so the best thing you're gonna do is
just let the air go if you try to hold
it in
you will damage your lungs you will
damage your throat it is going to be bad
news you just let it go
now and then the second thing that's
going to happen is that all the oils and
moisture on your skin
and eyeballs and tears and sweat and
everything are going to
instantly evaporate or sublimate into
space and just uh that's gonna cause a
little bit of damage a little bit of
burning on your skin but you're still
you're
okay the big thing that gets you is the
lack of
oxygen that's because your heart is
still pumping
blood is still flowing through you all
the time doing its thing
it just stops carrying oxygen because
there's no air in space and so there's
no oxygen
so in about 10 to 20 seconds your brain
is gonna go
gonna shut down you're gonna lose
consciousness you
can be recovered if you're pulled back
in and you can
live a relatively normal life
but if you stay out for a few minutes
then
as your organs start to lose oxygen
they will shut down and then when all
your organs shut down you
are dead so it takes a few
minutes for you to die in space when
exposed to vacuum
it's not instantaneous and you really
only have a few seconds
of of self-propelled maneuverability to
get you back into safety
so it's be uh far more excruciating than
some of the other ways that we recount
and at the end i'm going to ask you of
uh
your your preferred method of dying but
first before we get to the end
as it says in ecclesiastes better is the
end of a thing or a person than the
beginning thereof
uh but there's a certain poem that i
read
it's a it's a long poem it recounts the
epic
of a bearded sailor traveling across
time and recounting his travels at a
certain wedding ceremony
now my uh father and jim simons used to
enjoy their time on
long island sound on small fishing craft
at least until
one of them capsized it and get into
that but uh but the
the ancient mariner has a rhyme as well
and
in this book there's a lot from a
certain character named uh
the uh the rhyme of the ancient
astronomer i want to ask you
who is the ancient astronomer and is he
bearded
yes the each chapter opens with a few
verses
from the what's called the rhyme of the
ancient
astronomer which uh in the
setting of the book the book takes place
in the far
future where interstellar travel is easy
and cheap and lots of people want to do
it
and the the character the persona they
take on when i'm writing the book is
from like a grizzled
interstellar travel veteran who is you
know
oh you want to go into space well let me
tell you why you shouldn't because it's
long and arduous and dangerous and
difficult and also full of wonders and
beauty and discoveries
and so i imagined in that far-flung
future that there are collections
of sayings and stories
and phrases that have been passed down
through the eras where no one's exactly
sure
who wrote it when when they wrote it if
multiple
authors were involved where it's just a
collection of sayings to guide
people through the universe and it turns
out they're almost always cynical
yeah i was wondering about that and also
what the h index is of the ancient
astronomer
uh but i won't get into that right now i
want to ask you on the back of the book
it says paul
m sutter phd is the author of your place
in the universe
understanding our big messy existence as
well as the host of the ask a space man
podcast
he's currently a research professor at
suny stone he broke
incorrect well they say there's there's
typos and this should not be quoted so
this is the advanced reading it's fine
uh st
you were allowed to say suny stoner
brook state university
of new york at stony brook and also
stony brook university
how are acceptable brandings we are not
allowed to say ucsd
anymore it's uh it gets confused with a
neighbor to the north that shall remain
nameless but uh but then you're also a
guest researcher at the flatiron
institute
uh if a ancient astronomer happens to
time travel
back to uh new york city and wake you up
at three in the morning you do all these
amazing things
all these interesting things hardcore
scientific research
popular outreach popular writing
scientific writing
who are you who am i first off if a time
traveler
teleports into my home at 3 00 am i am
calling the police i don't care
what they say or what era they claim
they're from or what newspapers they're
holding
uh we are we are getting the police
involved i think the blasphemy
might shut that down i don't know if
you're allowed to get rid of them
uh we're i'm going to work on it listen
we're going to get some we're going to
get some firepower involved
now who am i yeah so so i'm an
astrophysicist i got my phd
back in 2011 at the university of
illinois at urbana-champaign
i working in giants computational
simulations
of stuff flowing out of giant black
holes inside of clusters of galaxies
then after i got my phd i went to the
paris institute of astrophysics where i
worked with don wendelt
on voids i was a member of the plank
collaboration studying the cosmic
microwave background which you are a
little bit familiar with
and doing all sorts of cool analyses
of radio interferometric techniques for
the first stars
uh then in 2014 i moved on to a second
research position based
in trieste italy where i continued those
research lines
would you work with there i have a lot
of good friends there carlo because um
mateo viel
was my sponsor there but i was largely
independent it was a fellowship so i was
i was working all over with with
everyone
nice uh yeah and a bunch of the people
that i've encountered
in paris and italy are now actually
working at the flat iron suit so it's
good to see a bunch of old friends again
and it was in the course of that second
postdoc where i started my podcast which
is
still running it's called ask a spaceman
we're on episode like 140 something now
and it was just an experiment it's like
i like doing outreach i liked giving
talks
i liked answering people's questions and
i wanted to put something out there in
the world
and i thought okay i'll just put it out
there i'll just do it
i'll just see if it's any fun i'll see
if i enjoy it i'll see if it resonates
with anyone
it turns out it kind of resonated with
people it turns out i really enjoy it it
really grew i
got a solid audience base right away or
after like six months or a year
of dedicated work in it uh i got a great
audience
that opened up other opportunities start
writing
to start hosting to start doing other
things and slowly over the course
of the past five years i've transitioned
from being
fully embedded in professional research
with a little bit of outreach to now
where i'm doing
almost entirely science communication
and outreach
uh with a little bit of research on on
this side so i still work on cosmic
voids and large scale structure i'm
still a member of some collaborations
and but but the majority of my time is
spent doing this is
is writing books and writing articles
and and hosting tv shows and doing
silly youtube videos and making up
lame jokes to put on social media and
doing interviews with with
other people like you and just having a
blast
yeah it really shows in the book uh and
i listened to the audiobook and read the
physical book and i advise everybody to
do that
and for the hat trick as we say throw in
the electronic book issue as well
uh you gotta have all three copies all
three versions but you narrated the
audio book which is something i did not
i had to audition for that i know i was
going to ask you about that you do have
a mellifluous
voice honed over many many episodes of
ask a spaceman
and probably some imbibations perhaps
some libations
oh just water man i can't clean yeah me
too yeah me too of course
uh but the uh but it really comes
through in the book
uh and the audiobook and certainly that
you have this infectious passion
for doing this and it kind of brings up
one of my next questions is about
uh what is the obligation i'm gonna be
provocative i'm gonna be you know a fox
news host here for a second if you'll
indulge me
uh yeah i'm gonna say it's cool let's
let's go down that road
yeah so uh so i i think scientists they
get paid by the public
except that they work for a large uh uh
institute uh such as yourself
or have a 100 million dollar project
funded by the same individual
but anyway we work for the public joe
taxpayer joe six-pack first of all why
should he care about
anything you talk about in your book
millions of years in the future perhaps
uh that's my first provocative question
why should we care
and then i'm going to get a little bit
more personal about scientist
obligations but first
why should joe six-pack joe bag of
doughnuts i don't know why his name is
always joe
let's call him let's call him uh clement
why should he kill clement's
bag of donuts hello mr bag of donuts
i hope you support me in the upcoming
election no you should care because this
is fun you should care because this is
interesting
you should care because trying to figure
out how the world works
is a part of who we are no
astrophysics like figuring out how black
holes work
or the earliest moments of the universe
it's not going to make
more efficient car engines or faster
internet it's not going to
change your material life but that was
never the point of science
in the first place the point of science
is that we
are curious we are a curious
people we are a curious species that
that defines us
art and music and dance and curiosity
are all
a part of who we are and science is an
expression of that curiosity
so you should care and i'm internally
grateful for your taxpayer support
to keep science going i recognize that
this is a privilege
of scientists to be able to do what they
do
science does lead to great technological
advancements that's more of a
fun byproduct and then the main point
but you should continue funding science
and you should care
about what astronomers are doing because
it's fun to learn new things it's fun to
explore and discover and be curious and
so you can read my book
and that this book is the result of
hundreds of years of trying to figure
out how the universe works
and if it surprises and delights you
and you enjoy it then you are
participating
in the very reason that science exists
indeed
now along those lines let me keep on uh
you know let me go to his wife
clementine a bag of donuts and uh
so you signed a coincidence of this
amazing privilege you're in your ivory
towers etc
you're good at it paul you're a
brilliant communicator you have obvious
infectious passion and joy in everything
you do
how come you know the researcher at the
state college down the street
how come she's not doing it shouldn't
she be forced to do it
uh shouldn't she be as good as you and
take as many classes in
in vocal coaching auditioning as you did
uh as as you did why does she get off
scot-free
and it doesn't have to do outreach to
the people i pay her salary
yep that's a very very good question so
uh
thank you for saying i'm very good i
really do appreciate it i didn't take a
single class
i didn't do a single coaching i make
this all up
as i go along and my skills have been
developed and honed over
years of just forcing myself to do it
again and again
as to other professors other researchers
should they do it
should they be forced to do it yes they
should i actually think it is an
obligation of scientists to communicate
their science to the public for exactly
the reason that you specified
which is the lar vast vast majority of
science
is publicly supported and if that the
results of that science
isn't being communicated to the public
in a way that
they can understand that is our fault
that is our problem if scientists are
continually surprised why there is
distrust
in science in a gulf between scientists
and the public
guess whose fault it is it is the fault
of the scientist
it's our fault so no
i don't expect a professor to launch a
podcast or host a youtube series or
write a book
okay but the incentives
in the academic world are
all wrong if you are a
uh upcoming professor or even fully
tenured professor
the way you advance your career the way
you get recognition among your peers
the way you get pay raises within your
university
of the way you better position yourself
within your department or your field
is by writing papers and getting grants
and that takes up
about 120 percent of your time
with the remaining negative 20 of your
time you are expected to serve on
committees
teach and then maybe have a family
preach brother preach
and and i think this is broken
the universities and institutions around
the world do not
incentivize public outreach and
communication
not necessarily in terms of a financial
word but they just
just don't make it part of the package
part of the expectations
of a professor or a graduate student or
a postdoc
and so no one bothers or largely no one
bothers because
there's no reason to do and there's only
so many hours in the day they've already
got 50 000 things they got to get done
and continually scientists
run into this roadblock of hey we have
new signs and then people don't
listen we complain about journalists
distorting
uh and running away with our headlines
and hyping up bad science
we complain that people aren't paying
attention to real science we complain
that people don't understand the
scientific
method and the scientific process
well who's better positioned to teach
people than the actual
scientists so what i go around whenever
i give talks
whenever i give a public talk i try to
connect with
the nearest university or college and
give a talk to their physics or
astronomy department
and talk about outreach and talk about
what i've learned from the front lines
and doing this myself and trying to make
a living out of it and
what they can do with small slivers of
their time so that it doesn't get in the
way of the research it doesn't get in
the way of their teaching
it doesn't get in the way of their
family but they can do
a small part in communicating science
whether on social media
or or instagram or writing a couple
blogs
or just making themselves available to
to reporters
either on tv or print of just
pushing a little bit to get
a little bit more science out there in
the public with no one in the middle so
it's direct
scientist to public exchange
you know for me i always liken it to
imagine there's an actor or actress
and uh and you say i've got this play
it's called hamilton
uh are you interested in being ah no i
don't care it's just you know probably
the most innovative play the last 50
years you know
we have some of the best material that's
ever been created in the entire
universe to speak about the very
universe itself
different aspects of this very smallest
structures the very largest structures
things that border on philosophy
theology and i always say when people
say that i'm not good at public speaking
you know i'm good at giving powerpoint
well you know you probably weren't born
good at quantum field theory but somehow
you made it work
right so it is about effort the only the
only partial disagreement i have
otherwise we have perfect uh you know
mutual admiration society
is that i i do think we should you know
as galileo said um
you know measure what is measurable and
make measurable
what is not so so in other words if you
don't have a metric to appraise or a
prize how someone's doing in this realm
as you're saying there's no incentive
first aspect of incentivization is to
have some kind of metric and say look
this is a component we expected of you
if you're not good at it we have these
things called
you know trainers and look you're proof
that you can do an amazing job build a
following
have a fan base uh predominantly i don't
think it's a source of immodesty but you
know because of the strength of
of the material and your education that
gives you that ability
um so uh so i the only disagreement i
would have is just to say yeah i think
we should train people and how to speak
look
most of our days as you said you know
have to do with uh writing papers or
getting funding and both of those are
persuasion right i mean both of those
involved
some amount of persuasion in fact jim
simon's like 90 persuasion
read any journal article on the archive
it is 90
persuasive and we never teach our
students this you know it's like they're
just naturally going to become gifted
i have students that are from all over
the planet and they not english native
speakers
and i would send them to toastmasters
and i would get them up public speaking
and i realized hey it doesn't just go to
my
student from thailand it also goes for
my student from uh from illinois
uh and what have you so uh so i think
we're in
good resonance there i want to read a
poem uh since i think science is a form
of culture and perhaps highest culture
maybe we'll get into that when we talk
about relativity in just a little bit
it's a poem called fire and ice written
by a frosty man named robert frost
he said some say the world will end in
fire some say an ice
from what i've tasted of desire i hold
with those who favor fire
but if it had if i if it had to perish
twice
i know enough of hate to say that for
destruction
ice is also great and would suffice what
is your preferred
method of cosmic or personal destruction
wow this is this is getting dark so
uh personal destruction okay it's either
um getting eaten by a hippopotamus or
uh just peacefully passing in my sleep
surrounded by loved ones
uh but when in the back of my car like
my grandfather as he was driving
uh but when it comes to the earth we're
gonna we're gonna burn to a crisp
so frosty was wrong i mean it was uh i
mean he's not a cosmologist so i'm
he had a 50-50 shot yeah so i recently
reviewed uh
professor katie mack's book um uh the
end of everything astrophysically
speaking
and uh i was musing about you know this
proliferation
first of all there's a lot of new work
on theories of everything and i want to
talk to you about
that i got a bone to let's do that but
first uh what's the eschatological you
know the fascination
with the other side normally we think of
you know the big bang
the origin of the universe maybe cyclic
cosmology however you like to phrase it
um and so but now we were talking about
the end of perhaps everything and
there's a lot of books nowadays coming
out what do you attribute that to
i think it needs two things one is
the far future of the universe is
a very strange very poorly understood
uh region of time where where physics as
we know it is going to completely break
down and
and we need new laws of physics to
ultimately understand it
just like the beginning of the universe
and so all
the fascination we had at the beginning
of the universe can apply to the end
where just things are going to be
different
in a very very strange way and so i
think there's always going to be some
set of
fascination with that topic and
the cool thing about cosmology is that
physical cosmology is we're
using science and scientific tools to
answer questions that
have bedeviled humanity for all of
humanity we've
always wanted to know
what is our place in space and time
how did this world arise will it
transform
will it end will it become something
else what are the rules that govern this
existence the
the this is the basis for like every
single cosmological model
um based in religion and also based in
physics
but in the past hundred years we've been
able to start answering these questions
using physics and develop the field of
physical cosmology
and begin to place ourselves in time and
space be able to sketch out the rules
that govern the universe
be able to answer some questions about
or begin to
start to try to attempt to answer some
questions about what the universe looked
like in its beginning state
and the very next thing is well what
comes next
okay we got the past we got the big bang
we got the now we have our universe well
what
happens next and so i think it's
always going to be a part of the
discussion i think it's always going to
be fascinating
uh that that little tantalizing thing
that seems
just out of reach of understanding is
always always going to be
absolutely fascinating right it reminds
me of this you know kind of fascination
that
elon musk has with going to mars and uh
he said he wants to die
on mars and i heard lord martin reece
who graced my book with a blurb
he said yes it's likely that elon musk
will die on mars he may die on
impact and i want to ask you if you had
uh
sort of a letter from god uh you know or
whoever your deity is
a letter from coffee i don't know uh but
uh you had
you had insurance you wouldn't take uh
clement bagadona
back again that's right um if you had
guarantee
you would not die in space uh which of
the celestial phenomena
that you so articulately portray in this
gripping book
would you most like to get close to and
up close and personal
you know i really it's so hard to pick
it's like picking your favorite kid
which is
everyone has a favorite kid but you
don't used to say a minute when i asked
her i would say you know who's your
favorite kid and she'd say oh that's
like asking me to pick
you know do i prefer my left hand to my
right hand i said mom you're left-handed
yeah left-handed you you have a genetic
preference for one hand
yeah so uh but you don't publicly say
which is your favorite kid but okay i'll
say
of all the phenomena that i visit in the
book and explore in the book
i am actually very very intrigued by
cosmic
strings i did a little bit of research
on them
you know so there are some lines of that
of
professional interest in them um
[Music]
just seeing a cosmic string encountering
a cosmic string
i think might answer more questions
about physics
than say encountering a black hole would
you talk about the black hole and it's
not often i get to talk with
such an astute observer and
knowledgeable professional
about uh about black holes about
relativity uh but luckily i talked to
nicholas eunice the other day no i'm
just kidding
i'm talking to you now but i do want to
get into a subject that i i did bring up
with clifford will
and uh and nicholas eunice who teaches
at your alma mater now
at urbana-champaign and they have this
book called is einstein still right
i had earlier this year i had professor
jim gates
on to describe his book proving einstein
right
soon i'll have lee smallin on my podcast
uh to discuss
uh einstein's unfinished revolution uh
and next year of albert einstein
i have eric weinstein on my podcast uh
but uh but you
make a lot of albert einstein in this
book he's he's kind of uh
you know an overarching protagonist in
many of these books
of course he died with this unfinished
revolution in some sense this theory of
everything
and i want to talk about it because you
mentioned things like quantum gravity
you mentioned
singularities what evidence do we have
that a singularity
even exists to motivate the need for a
theory of everything in other words
putting back on my
bag of donuts doctor bag of donuts to
you uh if i put that on
there's no proof of anything infinite in
the entire physical world
only in the mathematical world why
should i even care about a singularity
i don't think they exist oh that that's
the exact
point we don't think singularities exist
and
the presence of singularities in the
mathematics of general relativity that
gives raw
gives rise to black holes when you when
you figure out that black holes exist
and you see that there's a singularity
there that there's a point of infinite
density
your first instinct in the instinct of
many physicists 100 years ago would say
well then obviously it's wrong or it's
just an approximation or obviously we're
getting something right but black holes
don't really exist
fast forward a few decades we realize
that black holes do
exist and as the decades have progressed
resulting in the latest nobel prize like
black holes really
are a thing they really do exist the
citation to my friends
and guests uh upcoming and past guest
sir roger penrose
is for uh and andrea i guess up the road
here in the university of california
uh is for a compact object uh at the
center
of our galaxy not a black hole what do
you make of it okay okay fine like i'm
not gonna
i'm not gonna get into semantic
arguments with the nobel prize committee
i have enough problems with them as it
is um
but like it's it's about black holes and
this is not
the first nobel prize awarded for
something related to black holes
and and so we're like okay black holes
exist and they keep
doing all the things that general
relativity predicts them to do
uh and they keep behaving in the exact
same way we predicted
the the exact same properties and so we
keep
realizing that black holes are real
but all the math we have about black
holes tells us that there is a
singularity at the center there's a
point of infinite density
we know that's wrong we know that that
is a point where the mathematics of
general relativity is breaking down but
we don't know what to replace it
with and that becomes a major sticking
point and that's
where we want to figure out like okay if
black holes exist
like what's really at the center instead
of a singularity
that's right and i think the you know
the thing that speaks to me so much
about your book
in contra distinction to some of the
more flowerly
flowery whiz-bang you know this is so
amazing
is that you know you're presenting these
you're also an academic
and and it shows in the book with you
know 10 pages of endnotes
follow-up resources but that you freely
admit
at some points you say and it's fun to
hear your voice live but you know after
listening to you for the last 13 hours
straight
uh i'm sorry a sutter binge as i slept
uh but the but the point is you know you
bring up all the things we don't know
and that then you say this this
wonderful kind of imprecation
but mixed with uh with a blessing which
is go explore
and uh what about you know these
phenomena still
are left to explore i mean nobel prizes
equal solve
settled science don't they
um well the the book isn't to drive uh
future nobel prize
explorers uh the the book is meant to
drive curiosity
and wonder and we don't
even things that are close to home even
phenomena that we are familiar with on a
daily basis like
the sun there are still many unsolved
mysteries about
the sun or about the distribution of
comets
in our solar system like we haven't even
we're not 100 sure that the oort cloud
exists
we think it exists because we think
comments have to come from somewhere
but we don't know exactly where it is
how big it is its distribution
any of that everything we encounter in
the universe
even things that we have a lot of
answers about are still full of
mysteries there is
always more to learn and there are
always surprises
around the corner in some cases like
black holes or cosmic strings
the the mysteries are blatant and
obvious because our physics breaks down
and nothing makes sense
but but really mysteries are everywhere
and they're usually very quiet and very
subtle
and they're only there for those who are
willing to look for them
yeah and i had this conversation not too
long ago
um with uh with juan maldasena
at another institute he's
institutionalized also
and we're talking about one of his
recent papers called humanly
traversable wormholes and you
tangentially bring this up in the book
as well
and i asked him why should joe bag of
donuts
and i didn't bring that guy up because i
don't think he'd not say why did juan
you know empanada saw someone that that
he loves from our his homeland of
argentina
why would he care about these things
when we don't even know if the randall
sundrum
you know uh ads cft model 9 or whatever
it's predicated on exists and he's had
something very interesting
you know in the context of uh of
learning about
quantum mechanics from wormholes
learning about as you talk about
einstein rose and bridges is another
name for them
um and he said you know you can learn a
lot about something that may not exist
which i i found really fascinating
uh it's kind of the opposite of yourself
like we we know that some of the we know
comets exist as you just said we know
uh but we don't know yeah where is their
uh stable where is their birthplace
if if indeed that is how they come about
uh as well as some of the other
phenomena that were
once unknown and unknowable t-tory stars
all sorts of other things that we might
not have guessed type 1a supernovae
and and how they become important um and
i want to ask just getting back to your
academia in the
in the final few minutes before i ask
the standard list of questions that i
ask all my guests
uh including who you're going to vote
for no i'm not going to ask you that but
i want to ask you uh uh you know in
terms of the
academic side of things i asked nicholas
eunice uh who's
a fellow argentinian of uh juan maldisan
as i said what was the most like
inspirational uh
event in your field and he he didn't say
like discovering
you know gravitational waves he said
when pretorius came up with this
vast supercomputer simulation of the
coalescence of black holes and ring down
etc
what is sort of your like eureka moment
your wow
signal as you talk about in the book for
you specifically paul what what gets you
excited gets you interested
um and because we can't do it all we
only have 120
of our time you know uh to dedicate so
what gets you
excited about astrophysics the research
side
of your vast mental capaciousness
yeah i wouldn't point to any one
particular moment but
a daily a daily
waking up in the vastness of the
universe
in the sheer joy and incomprehensible
beauty of the fact that i can sit here
at my desk with my computer with my
chalkboard
i could be having a conversation
writing down equations solving them
running simulations performing analysis
doing all this sciency stuff
about a physical a particular physical
system known as the
entire universe where
i can sit with a cup of coffee and
discuss
with a colleague an event that took
place 13.8 billion years ago and we can
keep totally straight faces and we're
grounded in the evidence
and we're we're trying to discover and
analyze some some
particular part of the signal or or when
we talk about voids like
oh yes we developed a new mathematical
technique for identifying voids
these things are minimum 80 million
light years across
and we can just sit here and talk about
them
the same way we talk about breakfast
cereal that
the the the almost the absurdity of it
is what powers means like we actually
get to do this
all right then let's do it yeah and we
get uh we get paid for it
some more than others at those uh fancy
schmancy institutes uh that you are
institutionalized at uh
and a state employee well i guess you're
a state employee too you just have a
different governor that is your boss
uh i want to close with the three uh
final
into the impossible questions that i
love to ask first of all
you may be familiar with the uh our sir
arthur c clarke
who is the namesake of the arthur c
clarke institute for
uh for human imagination here at uc san
diego
and i'm the co-director of that august
institution or society or center rather
and uh in the movie 2001 a space odyssey
which was a
future forecast in the 60s of what uh
life in 2001 might look like uh have you
seen that movie paul
i have it's a wonderful movie it is and
so uh there are these
ominous sort of uh devices machines some
say
these monoliths that make appearances a
beginning opening scene on the plains of
the savannah of africa encountered by
some primates
later encountered on the moon and in
some sense they're meant to represent
a long-lasting time capsule produced by
an intelligent alien civilization
i want to ask you if you could make a
monolith if you could put the
the sutter monolith somewhere and it
would be discovered by an intelligent
species of something maybe a billion
years from now
what would you put on in about that time
capsule
oh good question i would probably
i would actually probably put art i
would probably put poems
and paintings and music
uh and i would put like uh mathematical
proofs
in there i would assume that a species
of billionaires now
has figured out all the physics and
understanding of the cosmos that we've
come to and more
and so i think our our feats of
technological
progress would not be very impressive to
them but
where our imagination goes how our
imagination and curiosity has driven us
how we've refined it through so many
beautiful fields like science
like dance uh i think would be of great
value
the next question also involves uh sir
arthur c
clarke and that is looking
backwards in time uh what uh sir arthur
is famous for his quips for his
aphorisms
uh the first one most famous one being
and we open every show with this uh with
him actually reading it it's pretty
amazing my producer stewart roll cow
found him
a clip of him reading uh any
sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic that's
arthur c clarke's first law
the second law and you and i resonate
with this i'm sure for every
expert there's an equal and opposite
expert
and then number three is the only way to
find
out what is possible is to venture
beyond the limits of the possible
into the impossible and that's sort of
than how i got the name for this podcast
and i want to ask you to a 20 year old
uh
paul sutter what seemed impossible but
now is eminently doable because you went
ahead and did it
oh yeah everything about my current
situation in life would have seemed
impossible to 20 year old me
i wasn't even a physics major when i was
20 years old i was in computer science
and it wasn't until my junior year um
shortly after i turned 20 that i
i switched majors and became a physicist
and so the concept of having a phd in
physics the con
the concept of uh making progress
in in this in a scientific field
the concept of having a podcast and like
doing
tv shows it would have been would i
would have
not understood uh future me
yeah and you think about you know a
scientific paper that you and i write
might take a week a month to write a
single sentence
and be read by 10 people if that and
that includes our
co-authors uh but your book it does not
include our co-authors and
they don't read anything all right uh
and then uh your books your place in the
universe
and how to die in space tens of
thousands of people read it
and many more by the audiobook and the
kindle edition hopefully
um and so yes it is kind of magical that
we're able to do this
and uh reach across and and have the
impact
uh you know i say i outsold you know i
got a bigger advance than nietzsche you
know and so that's saying something but
but in reality you reach so many people
and that brings us to the end of our
questions and i want to give it uh give
you an opportunity you talk a lot about
angular momentum
in the book and the power the sheer
power of angular momentum no no pun
intended
uh now i ask you to enter the spin zone
and please
plug where people can find the space man
all right you can go to my website which
is pmsutter.com or you can just google
search pulse center it'll come up
and from there you can get links to my
podcast
ask a space man my weekly radio show
space radio
you can get links to both my books your
place in the universe and how to dine
space both
and those are available on amazon and
barnes and noble the usual you can also
get autographed copies
from my website uh you can also get
links to my
show on discovery digital it's called
space out
and it's really really fun also links to
all my articles on space.com and live
science and universe today uh links to
all sorts of cool science and art
projects
like a project i do with a dance company
here in new york a
project i do with a emmy nominated
composer here in new york
uh all sorts of cool science and art
projects just go to pmstutter.com
it is the hub i put everything there
everything is there
everything rotates around it not unlike
an rr lyra star
creating a composition from its
neighbors
uh professor paul sutter it's been a
thrill and honor and a pleasure i hope
to get this out before
perhaps the earth comes to an end
hopefully not uh in the next few weeks
thank you so much for coming on the into
the impossible podcast
thank you so much for having me it was
really really fun
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from the magic
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you